[Musik]
herzlich willkommen zum heutigen video
how much cummings und uns dort geläufig
sind jetzt zusammen mit sp und luca zwei
lokalen pc spielen wer bin ich ihr
findet jetzt hier eine einsendung
eingestimmt nein was ihr wollt okay
leute genau sagen welche optionen ich
schreibe jetzt für sebastian ja das ist
das dritte wie ich bin ich also bei den
anderen jungs gibt es dementsprechend
auch videos und wir sind jetzt alle
wasted und deshalb wird es
wahrscheinlich dass beschissen sind
jetzt weg
ich habe nichts gesehen augen zu jetzt
auf einmal habe ich mir mein handy
man muss es sogar chinesisch schreibt
luca für heute um 17.15 uhr sich willi
will's wissen man sie wahrscheinlich
will das wissen will und das wilde
wissen was ich muss kurz nach gucken
musiker das nachgucken ersten fehler in
folge michael bublé seitdem laufe dieses
videos eine einblendung von meinem
merchandise machen wenn sie als erstes
findet und auch instrument postet hat es
gut gemacht ist es vielleicht gleich
wahrscheinlich kommentiere ich nur mit
den worten den vorderen kleber wie der
varese wie max ist so sinnlos da
irgendwelche wird ist lukas oft
geschrieben es ist eine sache die wir
entweder schon hatten die unterredungen
mit cannabis oder so etwas irgendwann
erfolg von dem youtube kann ich machen
was sagst du dazu
jetzt habe ich mal mit der frage ja habe
ich über eine million abonnenten ja über
zehn millionen abonnenten nein das wird
nicht funktionieren ob ihr serbe lux
raum
nein ich bin ich männlich bin ich
männlich und ich bin nicht männlich
yamaha kommen aus deutschland
nein so zwischen lukas erste aha und
seien ergäben sich höchstens eine halbe
stunde bin ich weiblich was ich kann
doch ein tier sein
ich habe tiere der geschlechter nimmt
ihre kanäle nein er hat mich ja deshalb
ist allgemein über so ein tier als video
kanada wird
ich bin weiblich ja junge spreche ich
deutsch in meinen videos komme ich aus
dort ja die person ist
wir müssen mal gucken was für ist wer
kommt doch nicht schon wieder aus
deutschland kommt aus deutschland
deutschsprachige videos mache ich auch
haben schon gesagt ja schon nachfrage
wohlig in nrw junge ja hier seit jahren
müssen den griechen keine fragen werde
doch ich stellte mir ja fragen wo nicht
in köln ja ich hoffe dass ich glaube ich
habe mich über viele verdammte scheiße
immer wie viel 400.000 leute übrigens
zwei abo fragen nicht über 500.000
400.000 auch nicht nicht über 400.000
naja ok dann sieht man zwar dass ich
weiß nein da die ja ihres ok oder
vielleicht alles klar habe ich schon
eine frage
hayabusa selbst beantwortet habe ich
unter einer million abonnenten ein
blogger com crafter nächste frage ich
habe von ihm und service
dazwischen eine million und zehn
millionen abonnenten und ich komme nicht
aus deutschland mache ich
englischsprachige videos ist einfach ich
mache ihnen gespeichert die das ok wohne
ich in amerika anders gefragt wohin du
willst wirst andere formen während wir
wohl nicht in der würdigung ist wohl
nicht
er hat noch nicht antwortet auf amerika
sieht der fragesteller gesichtsausdrücke
erwartet es wirklich ein du willst dich
in amerika also wenn ich in england kann
ja alle genießer dann okay nicht in
london
ich bin habe ich einen 2 unter 400.000
abonnenten sind komme aus prä mal
getroffen
ja absolut ich bin ja ein mann
nachweislich der anleger eingebracht
werden das mache ich so ähnlich wie wir
dass ich einfach so immervoll irgendwas
vor der kamera stehen irgendwas mache
also dass man sich wirklich ein und kann
so in die kategorie ich bin schon sagen
machen von dem besten von den papieren
des gerade zum beispiel von linda gray
diktat der abgesehen dem wr was es geht
michael bublé und mutter zweier alter
einer kabellosen auch der vater auch
unterziehen
also mit der main-post jetzt nein gehört
macht hat ihn einfach nicht und mache
ich musik
während manches gegeben ich war das für
mich eine feste stelle gerade
festgestellt dass keine handfesten
belege laut dem ist die anderen beiden
videos anschauen dass hier das verstehe
ich nicht mehr antreten ich mache musik
auf einem kanal schon mal nacheinander
von komme ich aus
ja ja ja ja das mache ich habe ich schon
mal musik auf einem kanal gemacht ich
[Gelächter]
hab ich schon da muss ich doch weil ja
ja
musik ist nicht so das hauptthema auf
meinem kann als ich mache nicht nur
musik richtig so richtig jaja wohne ich
in london kann gut sein weil es irgendwo
genau weiß ich nicht ich meinen blog
soll ich meine kurz nachschauen wie
sollen wir kurz danach mache ich was mit
himmel kräftig seien sie wie so viele du
willst dich treffen
leider muss keine blogs macht keine
blogs aha jetzt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich du willst dich doch ist gerade
das geld manche haben gesagt dass ich
mache anderen content als wir so viele
kugeln die katholiken die 4000 locker
das community gefühl augen sind am handy
also musst du dein handy gefoult
ich habe nicht gefällt man gib mir mal
den sieg also wenn ich in diesem video
geschummelt habe ich mit jedem von euch
10.000 euro geil gemacht leute habe ich
über 5 millionen abonnenten geht ja ich
mache ich popmusik er habe ich rote
haare
nein nein wie du mir das ja es gibt so
viele
ich bin ich habe ich einen hund kann ich
so weit nicht sehen würde ich bin da
eher sagen weil aber gehen wir mal ein
sieg ich will ja gar nicht geschummelt
habe gern der rauch komme ich ja schon
etwas aus liebe und das bo mission uk
platz kinder auf dem weg vom meer an der
verpflegung die formulierung und amerika
[Gelächter]
und es ist ja auch ein populärer musik
dafür also also sagen die tat so ich
würde sagen nicht so hip hop ich will
ich auch nicht sagen ich habe nein
gesagt okay jetzt muss ich sagen
hey weiß was ich an sie wollte wie wir
deutschland mit 4000 abonnenten oder so
eine youtube trend seite sowie youtube
trends ist youtube geht ok du kannst
dran
ich hab' ich hab die ganzen namen auf
der zunge liegen aber ich will nicht
unterstützt
ich sag jetzt einfach freund des block
bei einer verdammt war als apple meint
er jünger niemals keine burg dachte ich
war der den zwei bin ich seit über zehn
jahren erfolgreich im musikbusiness das
würde ich bejahe oder ich würde ich
schau mal da was ganz einfach
umformuliert mache ich seit über zehn
jahren musik
alle titel werden hat nur dem zufall
modus gespielt das mache ich seit über
zehn jahren musik und die hat spielt
gerade im zufall modus ebene liter also
mag sein ich habe nachts offen halten
aber ich bin wann ein nein hätte ich bin
fast noch gar nicht wahrgenommen oder
urlaub dran bin ja ja ja auch die fahrer
bin ich dass sie wieder gut nachdem du
schon bist du bist ich habe etwas angst
der bürger vor hilfe gelegt also habe
ich einen bruder würde ja auch ne also
ich gerne kennen gibt es und wie wirken
bin ich fertig bin ich
wie gesagt gar keine chance wahr sagt
ein junger gegen die gleichen tipp lass
uns direkt so macht mein tipp geben ja
das thema ratten jackman erst kommen
legt euch bestimmt sein hier winken max
richter den tisch ich sagte ja ich sage
dass ich würde sagen deine dame steht im
krassen gegensatz zu deiner statur nein
da kommen die leute das war vom heutigen
video ich hoffe mal ehrlich sein und
sagen wir bis zum nächsten monaten bis
zum nächsten monaten wieder was
hochladen und css kids